最近退職代行が流行ってるんですけど、
これご存知ですか?
うん。素晴らしいね。
ま、退職したいっていう人が自分で上司とかに言う代わりに
会社さんに依頼してっていうものなんですけどうん。うん。
これについて校長の意見を伺いたい。
大体退職の理由っていうのがしっかりしとるんかな。
自分のかなり勝手な理由になってないから
子供時代ていうのか非常にこう世の中を
甘く見る癖をつけさせられちまったやろ。
どうしても困ったら誰かが助けてくれるん
だという。そういう風に思わされちまった
よね。で、それが正しいんだというついで
にね。それは間違っとるよ。人の助けを
当てにするっていうのはいかんよね。から
ね。まずそういう困った時は誰かに助けて
もらおうという精神状態になってるという
ところが問題やな。それと弱いということ
な。リベラルは一生懸命強いのは悪いこと
というような教育をしてきたわね。だけど
強いのは正しいということなんよ。強いの
意味を知らずにみんな勝手なこと言っとる
けど。あれそういうことを言う人が弱いん
やろうね。だから強くする。
特に男は強くしないと使いものにならんよね。
校長の思想で一貫して強いものが正しくて弱いものは強くなるべきっていうのがあると思うんですけど。
そうそうそう。
これについてちょっと詳しく伺ってもいいですか?
正しいとは一体どういうことなんや?正しい精神と精神というのは行動のプログラムやろ。だから正しい精神で行動すると結果が出るんだ。
目的を達成できるだから正しいんじゃない
。弱いのは目的達成できないじゃない。
弱い精神でやったら。だから弱いのは
正しくない。それだけのことじゃない。
人間の行動には必ず目的
があるんだからその目的を達成するように
教育していかにゃ。今目的達成できなくて
よくできましたなんていうわけやろ。あれ
がいかんのや。
の強いものが正しいっていうのに対する反論で、
力が強い乱暴とかがよくあると思うんですけど、
これはどうですか?
だって乱暴って卵がついとるわけやろ。だから正しくないじゃん。暴力某がついとるんだから正しくないじゃん。精神的に強くないと弱いもんの非常に弱いものが危ないというのはダメだというのは行動がę素猫を噛むの行動になっちゃうんよ。
だから追い詰められたネズミがその恐怖で
行動する。そうすると叶うはずの相手に
向かっていくということやね。だから
間違った行動なんだ。恐怖でいきなり行動
すると間違った行動しちまう。あるいは
逃げる行動する。どっちも目的達成できん
わね。だから怒り怒りの方は立ち向かう。
これで行動すれば大体正しい行動ができる
。
乱暴物とかああいうおかしなやつらの見て
ごらん。あれ恐怖でやっとるから。体罰の
とこで言わんやったかな。1番する側とし
て怖いのは弱いやつがすると怖いんだ。
むっちゃくちゃやっちまうのね。間違った
行動するから恐怖で対人恐怖なんよ。だ
から生徒が怖いんだ、先生が。そうすると
恐怖で持って生徒に対する行動するをする
。むっちゃくちゃやっちまうんよね。いつ
までっても恐怖がなくならんからよから
恐怖で行動してはいかん。怒りで行動しろ
と正しい行動ができる。それを怒りでこう
怒りはいかんのだということをずっと言い
続けてきちまったもんでみんな怒りが弱く
なった。怒りが弱いのを
え精神的に強いていうことについて具体的
にどんな人どんな状態かもっと聞いても
いいですか?うん。ターウォーズで言っ
とったやないか。考えるな。感じろ。だ
から感じて怒りを発生する。これが強い
やつね。で、考えてあいつは俺より弱い
から言って怒りを発生するのはこれはダメ
だ。弱いやつのやることやね。からスター
ウォーズの中に出てくる言葉というのは
非常に資唆にとんどるやろ。ドントク
感じろ考えるな。で、もう1つは今のあれ
やね。
インスティンク本能を使えようと。本能は
善なんだから。本能による行動は善なんだ
から。最後がmaybewithユ。
ホースと共にあらんこと。ホースと共に
あるということは本能と共にあれという
ことやから全て本能で構造しろ。これ
は仏教で言うと空になるわけだね。授教で
言うと女になるわけだ。
女っていうのはどういう感じですか?
女はね、女、口、その下心授教の中ではジが
番大事な言葉なんよ。みんな人だと思っとるやろ。それはない。ジ内なんもジの中にあるの。え、ねからちゃんとこう俺が科学的と思う精神論授教仏教と大和魂みんなそうね、理性が間違っとるぞって言っとるわけ。
[音楽]
最近だと逆に弱い方が大きくなりすぎて、ま、逆差別っていう言葉だったりがあったりすると思うんですけど、これはどういう現象だと考えてます?
弱いものが強いわけないけども、マスコミの応援で強く見えとるだけやろ。だからもうしょっちゅほら今流行りのパワハ原ハ訟な光られたらパワハだって怒り出す。あれは弱いやつがやるよね。必ずね。やられた方はパワハラぞと言われた方はみんな負けるじゃん。
[音楽]
あ、おかしいよね。本人がダメだから叱られたわけやろ。そうすると叱った方が悪いっていうのはことやっとったら日本がダメになるの当たり前じゃん。
障害者が過剰に権利を主張するとかも問題になってますよね。
そうやね。あれは平等思想から来るわけやけど平等のわけないよね。だから平等思想ってのは必ず矛盾が来るやろ。
LGBTを少数者だから平等に扱えと健者
つったら奴ら起こるからと一緒に扱えと
言ったらばゲは女風呂に入ってもええと
いうことやからね。だけどあれを主張する
やつはゲを認めないとかね。自分たちの中
で争っとるじゃんな。自分だけを認めろっ
て言っとる。あれがいかんよね。平等
なんてないと思えええんだ。LGBTだっ
て身体障害者だろうと精神障害者だろうと
なるべく普通に扱う。これでおしまいよ。
なるべくだ。完全に普通に同じように
扱えるわけないじゃん。あれん時言った
やろ。招かれざる客の時に言っとるやつが
それができんね。自分の娘が黒人を連れて
きたら怒り狂っちまう。それが本当やない
か。人間として本能的に人種差別があるん
やからね。
それを人差別はいかんて言うからおかちなことになるん
あれがYouTube
にアップしたらなんか差別だみたいな感じで削除されちゃってまして
削除されたな。
はい。
ギメラルがやったか。これちょっとお話戻るんですけど職代行はまそもそもなんですけど上司にやめますって言ったりするのが気まずいとか難しいとかいう人が利用してると思うんですけど
そうやね。
これ自体が問題だっていう感じですかね。
自分のことやろ。自分で責任とってなあ、堂々と立ち迎えよと。あいませんでした。すいませんでしたと言いに行きゃええやないか。そんな難しいことやないよね。それが難しくてできんつったらちょっとおかしいと思わんあ。私には全く責任がありませんって言っとるわけやろ。今ね、強いやつのええとこは責任取るんだ。あるいは取らされる。
[音楽]
弱いやつのいかんとこはね、絶対責任取ら
んのだ。自分がメインとなって動いてない
からやね。人の言うままにしろ動かんも
で責任取らんでもええと思っね。
そんなものと独立あるいは個性がどうのこうそんなものとどうやってシュミュレートするん?
[音楽]
退職代庫を使ってる側の意見としては会社がいわゆるブラック企業とかパワハがひどいっていう場合はま、これを使うしかなかったっていう人もそういう声もあるんですけど使ええじゃん。だけど本当どうしてそんなとこに入ったんだ?調べてないんやろ?あるいはそこしか入れんやったんじゃないのか。
いかに自分で責任取らん癖がついとるというのは
新卒で退職代行その年のうちに使っちゃう人とかも結構増えてるみたいですね。
新卒ね。
はい。新卒1年目で
だったらさっき言ったような理由があるとしてもなんでそんなとこ入ろうとしたんや。
番多い理由がおそらくない。この会社は僕に会いませんという言い方やと思う。
うちの生徒の親で中華料理屋さんがおって
のは結構大きな中華料理店をやっとるんや
けどそこに来る入ってくる新人がみんな
そうらしいよ。1日持ったらええって言っ
とるんよ。お母さんと一緒にやってくるで
。お母さんがお前は仕事お母さんうちへ
帰る。そしたらもうダめや。お母さんの
そばにしかおれんのやな。ど分離不安
あんなものは入用児がやることをA年の
若者がやっとるんやな。
いかに進歩しなかったかということになるわけよね。
これさっきの動画でもおっしゃってた生命力というか打たれ弱いっていうのもこの対職代行とかに関係してくるんですかね?
そうやたれんことには撃たれ弱いに決まっとるじゃん。撃たれたやつが撃たれ強くなるんやね。からもう
つはね人は必ず撃たれるんだね。何もスーっとうまくいくやつがおるもんか。
[音楽]